hello my name is JD quen welcome to 3abn
today Bible
Q&A if you're like me this is one of
your favorite programs we've always got
lots of questions we're looking for
answers and so it's one of my favorite
programs because I'm going to hear some
answers first of all I just want to
introduce you to two only two of our
3abn family and we have Pastor James
rafy good to me good to see you thank
you JD it's great to be here I love this
program love getting into the Bible
getting answers to our viewers looking
forward to the Lord's leading amen we
like to see you in person instead of on
it's
nice and this is Mrs Quin Shelley Quin
yeah honey it's good to be here we are
going to do our best to answer I'm sure
yours are like this as well complicated
questions that you you could spend an
hour discussing but we're going to do
our best to give you answers from the
Bible I hope you got a pen and paper
just to jot down these scriptures as we
go through these quickly yes and thank
you for your questions yes and of course
these are your questions and so you've
got to get them to us how do you do that
we have three Avenues of getting it to
us number one if you like to text the
text the phone number is 618 228
3975 once again that's 618
3975 and then we have email if you like
to email them it's Bible QA at 3ab
bn.trek
if you like the Instagram it's
3abn uncore official and one more time
that's 3abn uncore
official now I'd like to go into prayer
we're going to lift us up to the Lord to
be guided by the holy spirit so that we
can go forward and uh with attent of
ears father as we come to you in the
name of Jesus we thank you Lord for time
we thank you Lord for energy we thank
you for stamina we thank you Lord that
you've given us Minds to understand and
father I thank you for the time that
you're providing here so that we can
share your word father lots of questions
come in lot of hungry people just can't
quite connect the dots and so father I
thank you Lord that you've uh allowed us
to have an Avenue to be able to share
that Lord we love you we thank you we
ask Lord in the name of Jesus that we
feel your presence in the name of Jesus
amen amen okay we've got I think each uh
James and Shelly they both have each
have uh five questions so we're going to
start with you James all right the first
question is I have always wondered about
prayer I have always wondered about
prayer that I do for my family for my
friends and enemies one day while
praying I also felt the need the need to
pray for Satan Am I Wrong to pray for
one that has fallen from heaven and
turned against God because he was an
absolute sinner please help me
understand and this is coming out of
California all right that's a that's a
really good question you know there are
some basic scriptures that speak to this
point um but before we go there I want
us to look at some scriptures in Matthew
12:
30-32 because we need to understand what
Jesus called calls the sin against the
Holy Spirit Matthew 12 30-32 Jesus says
this regarding the sin against the Holy
Spirit he that is not with me is against
me and he that gathers not with me
scatters abroad verse 31 wherefore I say
unto you all manner of sin and blasphemy
shall be forgiven unto men but the
blasphemy against the Holy Ghost shall
not be forgiven unto men and whosoever
speaks a word against the son of man it
shall be forgiven him but whosoever
speaks against the Holy Ghost it shall
not be forgiven him neither in this
world nor in the world to come now we
know that the devil and his angels have
committed this sin uh second Peter
chapter 2:4 and Jude verse 6 tell us
clearly that they are in Chains of
Darkness there is no light that can
penetrate their minds and their hearts
because they rebelled and sinned in the
very presence of God and he had no more
light to reveal to them and that really
is the process of sinning against the
Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit comes to
reveal light and Truth to us and as we
continue to reject that truth we come to
a place where there's no more light or
truth that can touch or penetrate our
hearts or our minds so with that
understanding of the unpardonable sin
let's move now to the Bible verses that
actually speak to this issue they answer
the question I think very directly 1
John chap 5 and we're going to look here
in verses 14- 16 of 1 John chapter
five John is speaking here about this
confidence that we have in verse 14 that
we have in him that if we ask anything
according to his will he hears us and I
love this this is a beautiful promise
that God has given to us that as we
believe in Christ we can ask anything
according to his will and he will hear
us verse 16 and if we know that he hears
us whatsoever we ask we know that we
have the petitions that we desired of
him so this is beautiful too because
this is basically just leading right
into the question that you've asked that
we should pray for anything and whatever
we ask we will get an answer if it's
according to his will but then he
there's a clarification that John gives
in verse 16 If any man see his brother's
Sin is Sin which is not unto death he
shall ask and he God will give him life
for them that sin unto death there is a
sin unto death this is the unpardonable
sin there is a son of death I do not say
that he shall pray for it so there's
your answer God is telling us very
clearly here that we are not to pray for
those who' have committed the
unpardonable sin now you may say well
how can we know if someone's committed
the unpardonable sin or not we don't
when it comes to human beings so we're
free we're we're we're free now to pray
for any human being whoever they might
be because we can't read the heart but
it's very clear that Satan and his
angels have committed the unpardonable
sin there's no more light that God can
give them and that's why they were cast
out of Heaven according to Revelation 12
so let's just take a look at this in
summary the only only sin the the only
sin unto death that cannot be we cannot
pray for is a sin against the Holy
Spirit that's what John uh Jesus is
making very clear in Matthew chapter um
12 now when it comes to human beings we
can't read the heart so we don't know if
a human being has committed this sin but
we so we can pray for all men second
Timothy for example chapter 2 says we
should pray for all men for kings and
those that are in Authority however when
it comes to the devil and his angels we
are told clearly they have committed the
unpardonable sin against the Holy Spirit
therefore this scripture in 1 John
54-16 applies to them we order not to
pray for the devil and his angels for
they have committed this sin the
unpardonable sin the sin that leads unto
death amen very good amen very good
Shelly I just saw this verse found in
Luke 10:20 in a Bible app devotional
could this verse be seen as a reason why
many believe once saved always saved and
this is from the state of Indiana
okay let's look at Luke 10:20 it says
nevertheless do not rejoice in this that
the spirits are subject to you but
rather Rejoice because your names are
written in heaven it is speaking of the
registry The Book of Life the Lamb's
Book of Life in Revelation 18 uh excuse
me Revelation 138 my very favorite
scripture it talks about the Lamb's Book
of Life the lamb who was slain from the
foundation of the world and Revelation
21:27 talks about the Lamb's Book of
Life here's the bottom line people some
people
believe once saved always saved but that
would violate God's
principle of the gift of Free Will he's
put a boundary around our free will he
will never violate that so if we come
into Covenant relationship ship with him
and then we break Covenant with him we
are blotted out of the book of life you
know when Moses went up the the children
the Hebrew children in The Exodus were
in Covenant relationship with the Lord
they broke the Covenant Moses went to
plead and say oh Lord brought my name
out if he he wanted to atone for them he
wanted to stand in as a substitutionary
sacrifice I here's what the Lord said to
him in Exodus
3232 and 33 he says Moses says yet now
if you will not forgive their sin if not
I pray blot me out of your book which
you have written that's the book of life
but the Lord said to Moses Whoever has
sinned against me I will blot his name
out of my book so it is possible to have
your name in The Book of Life and to be
blotted out we find this echoed in
Revelation 3 and verse 5 that God says
it kind of in a reverse way that he says
he who overcomes is Jesus speaking shall
be clothed in white garments and I will
not blot out his name from The Book of
Life when in Ezekiel 13 18- 20 God says
when a righteous man turns away from his
righteousness and does Wicked he'll die
because of it but if an unrighteous man
turns away from wickedness to
righteousness he will live because of it
God will judge each one according to
their record Jesus Echoes this and he
says in John
15:5 if anyone does not abide in me that
means to remain in him to dwell in a
covenant relationship with him he is
cast out as a branch and is withered and
they the Angels Shall Gather them and
throw them into the fire and they're
burned see God will not violate our Free
Will and you know Salvation is a gift by
Grace but it's our choice to remember a
to abide in Christ and I actually know
people actually who've been pastors
who've turned
away and
apostasis when David sinned in Psalm 51
um let me just look at it's 1 through
three he's saying have mercy on me
according to your loving kindness
according to the multitude of your
Tender Mercies plot out my
transgressions Wash Me thirst early from
my iniquity cleanse me from my sin we
see that's echoed in 1 John 1 18 and9
where it says if anyone confesses his
sin God is faithful and just to forgive
him his sin and cleanse him of all
unrighteousness so this goes both ways I
love it God said in uh Isaiah 1:18 and
19 come let us reason together though
your sins be like Scarlet they shall be
white as snow
he is the one in Isaiah
43:25 he says I'm the one who will blot
out your
transgressions so we're we're told to
repent and turn away from our sins so
that we can have times of refreshing
from the Lord I want you to read second
Peter 2 1 through
22 because Peter is warning of people
who will come along along and try to
teach once saved always saved and and as
Hebrews 3:12 says they depart from the
Living God so our God will judge us
according to our record if we've
confessed sins are blotted out our name
remains in the book of life if we don't
we can be plotted out amen amen good
James your second question is the
Thousand-Year reign of Christ a literal
thousand years would that mean that
there will be 1,000 years between
Christ's coming and the second
resurrection of the Dead without
Christ that's a great question and we
find the answer to that question in
Revelation CH 20 if you'd like to open
your Bibles there to Revelation chapter
20 yes uh the thousand year reign with
God and Christ in he in heaven is a
literal 1,000 years years that's very
clear here as we read Revelation 20 this
means that there is exactly or a
thousand years between Christ's second
coming and the resurrection of the dead
as you inferred in the question so let's
just take a look at these verses because
they're pretty clear I remember the
first time I ever read these verses some
40 years ago and I thought ah there's
nothing complicated about that you just
read through the verses and it all makes
sense I saw John says an angel come down
from heaven having the key of the
bottomless pit and a great ch in his
hand and he laid hold of the Dragon the
old serpent which is the devil verse two
of Revelation 20 and Satan and bound him
a thousand years and cast him into the
bottomless pit and shut him up and set a
seal upon him that he should deceive the
Nations no more till the Thousand Years
should be fulfilled and after that he
must be loosed a little season now all
of this is highly symbolic language it's
talking about the chaining up of Satan
not with a literal chain but with a
chain of circumstances and we're going
to read about those circumstances we
continue to look through this chapter
verse 4 and I saw Thrones and they that
sat upon them and judgment was given
unto them and I saw the souls of them
that were beheaded for the witness of
Jesus and for the word of God which had
not worshiped the Beast neither his
image neither received his Mark upon
their foreheads or in their hands and
they lived and reigned with Christ a
thousand years so this is a picture of
those who are resurrected at the second
coming of Jesus Christ those who are
sleeping in Christ those who are alive
when Christ comes and all of them are
taken to heaven and Thrones are set up
and they sit in judgment upon those who
are lost and upon the fallen angels as
Paul says in uh 1 Corinthians and they
Reign they live and reign with Christ
for 1,000 years that actually that might
be second Corinthians I can't remember
which verse that is but if you read
first and 2 Corinthians you'll find
where Paul says we are going to judge
angels I think it's 1 Corinthians and
then it goes on to say in verse 5 but
the rest of the Dead live not again
until the thousand years were finished
this is the first resurrection now Jesus
talks about this first resurrection in
John chapter 5 obviously this is
speaking to those who are saved or
believe in Christ but the rest of the
Dead the wicked who are destroyed at the
brightness of Christ coming they don't
live again until the thousand years are
over and this is why Satan is chained up
he has no one to tempt all of the
righteous all of the saved are in heaven
with Jesus Christ reigning for a
thousand years and everyone else is dead
and so Satan is in this chain of
circumstance on this Earth this Abyss
like a bottomless pit with form and
without void like it was before God uh
put his creative power over it he's
sitting here with broken down cities for
a thousand years kind of like in
isolation if you will you know he and
his angels looking at all their
handiwork all the terrible things that
they had done all of the pain and
suffering all of the destruction they've
caused for 1,000 years contemplating all
this while we're in heaven and the
wicked are dead but it says there's
going to be be uh a resurrection of the
wicked because it says the rest of dead
are going to live again they don't live
again until the thousand years are over
blessed and holy verse 6 is he that has
F part in the First Resurrection on such
the second death has no power but they
shall be Priests of God in Christ and
shall reign with him for a thousand
years and when the thousand years are
expired verse 7 Satan will be loosed out
of his prison he will go out to deceive
the Nations which in the four corners of
the Earth all of a sudden the nations
are alive again all of a sudden there's
people again this is the second
Resurrection the resurrection of the
wicked and as soon as they're
resurrected Satan goes out he's released
in the sense that he can tempt them
again he goes out to deceive them goam
MOG to gather them together to the
battle the number of whom is as the sand
of the sea they go up on the breadth of
the earth they surround the city Saints
about and the Beloved city which has
come down from God out of heaven and
Fire come Downs comes down from God out
of heaven and devours them it's pretty
simple it's pretty basic it's pretty
clear when you read through these texts
don't put anything in that's extra just
read through them and it'll all make
sense and you made sense good praise God
Shelly your second this is coming from
Nigeria does prayer change the mind of
God boy that's a great question and let
me give you a simple answer no prayer
does not change God's mind it changes us
and it changes circumstances let's look
at this God is immutable he does not
change he says in Malachi 3:6 I the Lord
I change not Hebrews 13:8 Jesus is the
same yesterday today and forever James
1:17 there's no shadow of turning in him
he never turns from his righteousness so
since God does not change his mind does
not change Isaiah
46:10 he says I'm The God Who declares
the end from the beginning and my
counsel will stand he says in Psalm
3311 the counsel of the Lord stands
forever the plans of his heart to all
generations so God is dealing with us
according to his counsel he has supreme
authority Ephesians 1:1 says that he
works all things out together according
to his will he never changes his
Covenant
promises or his un uh changing decree
against the wicked but numbers 23:19
says God's not a man that he should lie
nor a man that he should repent has he
said and he will not do has he spoken
and will he not make it good now you can
say wait a minute the Bible says he
repents when the words regret relent or
repent are used of God in the Bible
watch in context what it is is these are
what they call
anthropomorphic Expressions that means
we are attributing to God human
Expressions cuz we don't understand God
let me give you an example Jonah 3:10
says God repented of his judgment
against ninfa why because they
repented of their wickedness God didn't
change his mind he sent Jonah in there
for this very purpose and they followed
the purpose so he didn't have to bring
the evil against them I found this
beautiful quote from patriarch and
Prophets uh page 630 Ellen White says
man's repentance implies a change of
mind God's repentance implies a change
of
circumstances and relations so when we
pray if you think why should we pray
well it's not going to change God God's
Eternal will but prayer changes us and
it brings God's blessings down from us
you remember earlier I was talking about
God has given us the gift of Free Will
he's put a boundary you know what he
won't even Force His blessings on us so
as we pray it pre and especially as we
pray and ask as Jesus did that his will
be done It prepares our heart for his
actions I think of 2 Corinthians
12:9 I love this this is the
response uh Paul is praying three times
remove the thorn from my flesh please
Lord Jesus says my grace is sufficient
for you my PO is made perfect in
weakness he left Paul in that condition
to keep Paul humble to keep Paul
dependent upon him but prayer is a
commandment
we're supposed to pray but it is the
breath of our spiritual life
communication is the relationship so you
want to pray knowing that it's it's
important to pray according to God's
will I just have to end with this in
James 42 and3 James says hey you don't
have because you don't ask or you ask a
Miss to use it for your own pleasure
pray and watch how God will change your
circumstances in accordance with his
perfect will amen amen very good you
know it's something because Jonah
understood that too when at the end he
said I knew it yeah I knew it I knew you
I knew what kind of God you are yeah
yeahuh love it James can you please
explain Revelation
14:1 Revelation 14 : 11 let's just start
with reading the verse it's uh part of
the Three Angels message it's a powerful
verse it says the smoke of their torment
ascends up forever and ever and they
have no rest day nor night who worship
the Beast His Image and whosoever
receives the mark of his name now the
context of this is important because
this takes place we're told in verse 10
in the presence of the Holy Angels and
in the presence of the Lamb a lot of
people leave that out we need to
understand that there is a teaching out
there that's not really biblical but
they use the Bible that teaches that God
is going to torment people in a place
called hell for all eternity and this
verse is sometimes used to support that
idea but we want to recognize here that
the presence of the Holy Angels and that
the presence of the Lamb is where this
torment takes place that is described as
taking place forever and ever now when
you look in the Bible you're going to
find that this phrase forever and ever
is explained in the context of the Bible
we use it sometimes in our own language
you know when we're waiting for
something and it's taking a long time
and maybe even we're in a position of
you know hunger you know we got hunger
pains and we're just tired and sore it
seems like it takes forever one of the
things that I don't like that takes
forever sitting in traffic oh man that
is like the worst torture for me to sit
in traffic I don't know if you going to
relate to that and this is what we see
in the Bible in fact in Jonah chapter 2
Jonah is describing experience what
feels like he's going through hell he
feels it says here that he cries out of
the belly of Hell in a sense because
those experiences can feel so tormenting
and then he says in verse 6 of Jonah
chapter 2 I went down to the bottoms of
the mountains the Earth with her bars
was about me forever really for forever
Jonah really forever no actually for
three days you know the Bible tells us
that especially in the New Testament
Jesus says As Jonah was in the belly of
the well for three days and three nights
but it feels feels like forever when
we're in an uncomfortable situation or
circumstance so this no rest day or
night is is to it needs to be explained
in the context of the Bible this this
forever phrase needs to be understood in
the context of the Bible Isaiah 28 does
a really good job of explaining the
destruction or the um end of the wicked
in Isaiah chapter 28 we could start with
Verse 18 your Covenant with death will
be disal your agreement with hell shall
not stand when the overflowing Scourge
shall pass through then you should be
trotten down by it a lot of people think
the grave and death is the end of life
there's no future judgment there's
nothing else after that God says no
that's all going to be ended you are
going to be held accountable all of us
are going to have to give an account and
for those who haven't put our faith in
Jesus who haven't trusted in him we're
going to have to receive the reward of
all of the wickedness and evil that we
have sown in our lives verse 19 from the
time that it goes forth it shall take
you for morning by morning it shall pass
over by day and by night and it shall be
vexation only to understand the report
that is the report of the Gospel the
good news in the contrast to our
rejection of it for the bed is shorter
than a man can stretch himself on it and
the covering narrower than he can wrap
himself around it for the Lord will rise
up verse 21 in Mount peris and he shall
be wroth is in the valley of gibian he
will do his work his strange work and
bring to pass his act his strange act
it's the destruction of the wicked that
the execution of Destruction for those
whove rejected Christ is a strange work
we need to recognize that the wicked
will be punished in the presence the
very presence of God and the Holy Angels
this punishment will take days uh as
Isaiah says morning by morning day by
day and By Night the devil will suffer
the longest uh all according to their
works is what we're told and it will
seem like forever because it's not a
nice experience it's a terrible
experience it's a strange work Paul
warns about this in 2 Corinthians 5:11
where he talks about the terror of the
Lord in Hebrews 1031 29 also talk about
how fearful a thing it is to fall into
the hands of a living God who is a
consuming fire who will consume and
annihilate the wicked in his very
presence so the wicked will not suffer
for all eternity that's the good news
there will be a new Heaven and a new
Earth there will be no more pain no more
suffering No More Death the righteous
will be perfected with new Mortal bodies
and the wicked will be no more very good
very good I might just throw this in
James and you certainly can verify this
if traffic jams are a problem in your
life you can move around Thompsonville
West Frankfurt Illinois absolutely that
will solve that yep that's right
population
600 Shelly your third question uh this
is coming from Glenn in Australia what
happens to folks who have accepted
Christ but have not gone through the
process of
sanctification I'm thinking about the
thief on the cross who to my
understanding was justified by faith but
not sanctified
then I wonder about folk who find Jesus
just before the close of probation or
just before they die but have not had
time to go through the process of
sanctification aren't we meant to have a
perfect character at the second coming
of Christ Glenn this is a beautiful
question and a complicated question let
me try to make it simple in Luke 23
39-43 we see a snapshot of salvation by
grace Christ is Christ ified between two
thieves one recognizes him as Christ
confesses his sin asks for his mercy and
Jesus grants it and yes he was justified
by faith because of his
repentance the other snubbed the Lord
and was lost but when we think about to
be justified means that the Christ
righteousness is imp imputed or credited
to our account God it it covers all the
forensic evidence and God sees us as not
guilty he declares us not guilty free of
the penalty of sin but now your question
is about
sanctification let me begin with 1
Corinthians 1:30 I'm skipping through
all my notes because I'm not going to
have time but 1 Corinthians 1:30 through
31 MH speaks of Christ saying of him you
are in Christ Jesus and Christ Jesus who
became for us wisdom from God and
righteousness and
sanctification and
Redemption that as it is written he who
glories let him glory in the Lord what
does he mean salvation Belongs to the
Lord justification is one aspect of
righteousness by faith sanctification
simply means to be set apart from sin
and this is a second act of
righteousness by faith but listen
Hebrews 10:10 Believers are Sanctified
set apart it says we have been
Sanctified through the offering of the
body of Jesus Christ once for all then
verse 14 by one offering he has
perfected forever those who are being
Sanctified I want to read this is the
infused righteousness of Christ in us
and listen to this sanctification
Belongs to the Lord I'm in 1
Thessalonians
523 it says now may the God of Peace
himself sanctify you completely
and may your whole Spirit soul body be
preserved blameless at the coming of the
Lord sanctification we need to cooperate
with the Lord but at every it's God's
work Exodus 3113 even says one of the
the uh symbols or one of the meanings of
the Sabbath God says is it's a memorial
that you will remember I am the Lord who
sanctifies you so to your point to your
question the thief on the cross was
justified by faith in Christ he was
Sanctified by the offering of Christ as
well separated from sin at each point of
sanctification each stage we are made
perfect in that stage sanctification
belongs to God and it doesn't matter
whether it was the thief on the cross or
those who at the the end are young and
just beginning their walk with the Lord
or who have just accepted him they are
also Sanctified by the blood of Christ
and it's important to remember salvation
Belongs to the Lord amen amen we take 30
seconds here to go over contact
information again if you want to send
your questions in if you want to text
them 618 228 397 5 if you want to email
them it's Bible QA
3abn.org
to your fourth question yes sir I have
heard many times that Christ was tempted
in all points like we are but did not
sin and he suffered everything that
we've suffered but Christ was not a
abused as a child he had loving parents
if he had been a victim of child abuse
he would have been damaged and so he
could not have done the work of the
Messiah so how can people say he
suffered everything we suffer this is
from
Christine that is such a good question
Christine thank you so much for sending
that question in this is so important
and of course it makes sense I mean
Christ was no Haron addict for example
uh he didn't have an alcohol problem uh
in fact Christ never sinned and
therefore he could not be tempted with
cultivated sins or uh Tendencies or
propensities like we face when we're
tempted so how do we reconcile this with
what the Bible clearly teaches and that
is that Christ was tempted in all points
as we are and he can sympathize with us
in all of our Temptations the Bible
doesn't contradict itself and so we need
to look at this from a bigger
perspective so we're going to do that by
looking at 1 John chap 2: 156 and 17
these verses are the basis for all
temptation these are the scripture
references that help us to understand
how Christ was tempted in all points
like as we are from a Biblical
perspective without putting our human
reasoning into this because sometimes we
want to bring our human reasoning and
say well you know Christ didn't do this
and Christ didn't do that and Christ
wasn't this way and Christ wasn't that
way and therefore no let's just let the
Bible tell us what this looks like so
the Bible says here love not the world
neither the things that are in the world
that's a big picture right there that's
the whole uh apple pie so to speak right
that's the whole Piñata love not the
world neither things that are in the
world for all that is in the world
everything that's in the world the lust
of the flesh the lust of the eyes and
the pride of life is not of the father
but is of the world so God is is
summarizing this for us right here that
we are not to love the world I.E the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
and the pride of life all that in the
world are categorized in these three
areas the world will pass away verse 17
the lust thereof but he that does the
will of God abides forever so you have
here a contrast between the world and
everything that's in it that is
categorized under the three categories
of the lust of the flesh the lust of the
eyes and the pride of life and the will
of God which is what Christ always did
the will of God was in contrast in
Christ's life to everything else in this
world whatever it was now the second
section of scripture we want to look at
is in Luke 4 and we could just as well
look at Matthew chapter 4 but Luke
chapter 4 is where we're going to go
these are the actual Temptations of
Christ in the wilderness after Christ
was baptized and filled with the Holy
Spirit the spirit led him into the
Wilderness he was there with the father
for 40 days and 40 nights shut him with
God did not eat a thing and after this
40 days and 40 nights he was tempted of
the devil this this 40 days and nights
of fasting prepared Christ to experience
Temptation on a level that was much more
intense than we might experience it and
it was important because in the
wilderness Christ is going to be tempted
on guess what the lust of the flesh the
lust of the eyes and the pride of life
right these are the three categories the
main categories of Temptation from which
all temptations that are in the world
come according to 1 John 2:15-17 and
they stand in contrast with doing the
will of God which was is what Christ
always did the first temptation is found
in these first verses verse four uh or
verse three the devil said in him if you
be the Son of God command that this this
Stone be made into bread that's the lust
of the Flesh and you can imagine Christ
was hungry but he didn't succumb he
didn't respond he said it is written man
shall live by bread alone not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of God Christ
is turning to the scriptures that's our
example he's resisting the lust of the
Flesh and that category under that
category comes every other lust of the
flesh a heroin addict experiences every
other lust of the flesh that an
alcoholic experiences that a sex addict
experiences all of the lusts of the
flesh come out under this category then
you have the lust of the eyes that's
found in verse five when or verse uh uh
yeah verse five and then you have the
pride of life uh in verses 9 and onward
these are the three basic categories
that Christ had to be tempted in so that
he could relate to us in all of our
Temptations so so what we've just read
is really eye opening because it offers
this insight into how Christ was tempted
in all points like as we are and these
statements might even challenge some of
us who have not understood Christ and
Temptation some of us want to make
Christ all together like we are we can't
do that he was that Holy thing born of
the Holy Spirit from birth now we can be
born of the Holy Spirit and therefore be
Brethren with him Sanctified with him
according to Hebrews chapter 2 but the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
the pride of life are the three leading
temptations that Satan uses to assault
all of us all of Satan's manifold
Temptations come out of these Christ
experienced these assaults and therefore
he was tempted in all points such like
as we are very good Shelly number four
what's so special about God's people
having been selected or predestined to
be saved by grace we've all fallen short
of the glory of God and God doesn't have
favorites nor deserves salvation by
merits I believe there are so-called
Christians who wouldn't give up their
own lives to save someone else also
believe that there are non-believers who
would please
explain well you've hit on one of my
favorite scriptures Romans 3:23 and 24
the first part says for all have sinned
and fallen short of the glory of God but
then Paul says being justified freely by
his grace through the Redemption that is
in Christ Jesus yes we're all Sinners
salvation by grace being predestined
that's no merit to humanity humans
cannot take any Merit there's nothing we
can do to earn salvation so what's so
special about this predestination is it
shows us God's plan before he even
created the world that he had this plan
in place Revelation 138 that he would
come become the son of man become the
lamb who was slain from the foundation
of the world here's something that we
have to remember God's Act of
predestination it's not for a few it is
for all in Ezekiel 3 3 and verse 11 God
says as I live I have no pleasure in the
death of the wicked but that the wicked
would turn from his way and live now
listen to God's pleading turn
turn turn from your evil ways for why
should you die Romans 2:4 says don't
despise his goodness his forbearance his
longsuffering his patience
with us do you not realize it's the
goodness of God that leads us to
repentance First
Timothy Chapter 2 verses 3- 4 says he's
talking about what is good and
acceptable in sight of God our savior
who desires all men to be saved and to
come to the knowledge of the truth
second Peter 3 and verse n the Lord is
not slack concerning his promisees some
count slackness he's longsuffering he's
patient toward us not willing that any
should perish that's not his will that
mankind should perish but he won't
violate our freedom our Free
Will Ephesians 1 and 12 says in him in
Christ we have obtained and inheritance
being
predestined according to the purpose of
him who works all things according to
his will that we who first trusted in
Christ should be to the praise of his
glory Romans 8:28 tells us what our hope
is as Christians it says that God works
all things together for our good for
those who love the Lord and are called
according to his purpose that's all of
us who accept Christ but then he says in
Romans
8:29 this is our destiny how he works
all things together for our good is it
says because those he forne who would
come to accept Christ he predestined to
be conformed to the image of Christ
you're right there are some who claim to
be Christians who would not give up
their life for another there are some
who aren't Christians who would step on
a landmine to save others but that
sacrifice will not save them dying for
someone else isn't going to save you
we've got to know that the wages of sin
is death but the free gift of God is
eternal life through our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ very good
Shelly James this is from Dorene yes sir
why is leaven bread like s that was a
quick Snappy question Dorene thank you
for that question you know the Bible
uses illustrations uh that are practical
we could call this the baker's
illustration if you would and the
scripture actually refers to leaving
bread in both positive ways and negative
ways for example in the following
scripture in Matthew chap 13 and verse
33 Jesus says another Parable spake he
unto them the Kingdom of Heaven is like
unto Leen which a woman took and hid in
three measures of meal till the whole
was LE well there's leing and bread
that's used in a positive sense to
describe the Kingdom of Heaven the
Kingdom of Heaven is like Le bread and I
love bread especially when it rises well
my wife makes some amazing homemade
bread so really it is the nature and the
work of the leing process that is being
discussed here and not the actual
leaving in itself let me just explain
what I mean by that leaving bread is a
way or an illustration that God uses to
remind us of how sin works but also at
times to remind us of how the Kingdom of
Heaven Works how God works uh it's this
uh process of permeating and influencing
whatever it is that it's put into the
Holy Spirit seeks to come into our
hearts and it seeks to influence our
actions and our hearts in a positive way
sin comes in and the same process can
take place in a negative way Paul talks
about this in 1 Corinthians chapter 5
let's look at verses 6 through 8 of 1
Corinthians chapter 5 he says your
gloring is not good know you not that a
live little leave leaveth the whole lump
Purge out therefore the old leave that
you may be a new lump as you are
unleavened for even Christ Our Passover
is sacrificed for
us therefore let us keep the feast not
with the old leeven neither with the
leave of malice and wickedness but with
the unle bread of sincerity and truth so
here Paul is actually going back now to
this
Passover uh observance that was given to
the Jews where they weren't supposed to
have leave bread and he's likening
leaving here to uh the negative
influences uh of sin in our lives and
the malice and the wickedness that needs
to go out and the the unleaving bread to
the sincerity and truth of the Christian
experience and we could take this and
say well you see there's an example uh
the Bible uses leing in a negative sense
it does but again in Matthew Chapter 13
it also uses it in a positive sense and
we want to we don't want to get stuck on
the illustration we want to see what the
illustration is trying to communicate to
us so in these verses leaving is a
negative it's used to describe you know
self- Glory uh unleaving bread is a
symbol of sincerity and truth but
remember this is an illustration God is
Not forbidding the use of leaving God is
not saying if you use leing you're
sinning or leing is sin but he's using
it to illustrate spiritual wickedness
for example look in Jer at what Jesus uh
says uh in in Matthew 16: 7-12 verse 7
then Jesus said unto him take heed and
Beware of the leaving of the Pharisees
and of the Sadducees this dees are like
what is he talking about what is he
talking about Jesus says in verse 12
then they understood how that he bade
them not to be to not beware of leaving
a bread but of the doctrine of the
Pharisees and the Sadducees and again in
verse in Luke chap 12 verse one in the
meantime when there were gathered
together an innumerable multitude of
people in so much as they had troed upon
one another he began to say unto his
disciples first of all beware ye of the
leaving of the Phar es which is
hypocrisy so there we go Jesus is using
leaving here to illustrate hypocrisy to
illustrate the uh experience of the
Sadducees and the Pharisees uh which was
uh bad but he's not saying leaving in
and of itself is bad we use it all the
time for bread and in that purpose it's
good amen wow I've always said leavened
and unleavened but it's leav I don't
know it might be le I might have got
that wrong thank you for the
clarification I don't know I've never I
just figured it was British
yes maybe that was my British side oh
shot we got about 3 minutes left your
last question I've heard that after one
gets baptized the holy spirit will be in
their body to protect them and help them
fight Satan's attack is that true that's
from Linda Oh Linda what a beautiful
promise and and let me tell you this uh
we can't put limits on the Holy Spirit
most generally speaking when you accept
Christ as yourself Savior and you will
be if you know about the Holy Spirit you
can invite the Holy Spirit right into
your life right then and there before
your baptized but does he help us oh you
bet Jesus said in John 111
12-13 that is many as receed Christ as
his savior that the holy spirit is is
ours we're born again we see that in
John
3:3 and verse 7 and 1 Peter 1:23 but
here's the beautiful
promise God gives us everything we need
through the Holy Spirit living in us
actually the Bible says in read
Ephesians 3:16 through uh 21 Paul's
saying to the Ephesians oh I pray that
he would Grant you to be
strengthened with might it's a dynamite
power how through his Spirit In Your
Inner Man
so that Christ can dwell in your hearts
by faith and that you may know the love
of God and how wide and big and high and
deep it is but when this happens when
the Holy Spirit comes your question is
can he help us against Satan's attack
when he comes when Christ lives in Your
Heart by faith he says in 2 Peter
13-4 his divine power has given us all
things that pertain to life and
godliness through the knowledge of him
who called us by his glory and he has
given us his exceedingly great and
precious promises so please listen to
this Linda write down this scripture
reference Romans
8813 through 16 Paul says if you live
according to flesh you will die but in
if by the spirit you put to death the
Deeds of the body you will live the holy
spirit's not going to force you but God
will not let you be tempted beyond your
ability to stand you it's if by the
spirit you put to death so the two of
you have to cooperate you have to
cooperate with him and he will help you
amen amen thank you amen why don't we
take a couple of minutes here and then
we'll come back with a uh the contact
information and uh some closing
thoughts if you're enjoying our 3abn
Bible Q&A then tell your friends each
Monday we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org to uh talk with Linda just a
little bit more you know one of my
favorite verses Romans 8:15 says that
when the spirit of adoption is in Us by
him we cry out AB by father it it brings
us into this intimate relationship with
the
Lord and Romans 8:26 says The Spirit
Well we know he's our teacher pray for
him before you read the word ask his
help but Romans 8:26 tells us that he
helps us to know how to pray he
intercedes for us and then Philippians
2:13 that it is God by the power of His
holy spirit living in you that will to
he works out for you to Will and to do
his good pleasure amen James you have
anything to add I just going back to
that question about the Temptations you
know Christ was tempted in the
wilderness to turn stones into bread
when was a last time you were tempted to
do that turn stones into bread yeah we
can't do that Christ was the only one
that could do that he was tempted to use
his divinity and he was tempted to do a
good thing he was hungry we're tempted
to do wicked things Christ was tempted
to do a good thing and he had the power
within himself so when we look at Christ
Temptations being tempted like us we
have to look at the principles the lust
of the flesh the lust of the eyes the
pride of life we don't want to get too
into the nitty-gritty too much because
then we're finding going to find a lot
of contradictions but just put it in
this perspective Ive it must have been
much harder for Christ knowing the power
he didn't have to run down to the
grocery store he didn't have to go down
to your local you know legal marijuana
store or whatever you know get his
alcohol or whatever he could just snap
his fingers and there it was that makes
Temptation much harder on that level
agree I
agree well listen let me finish with
this this is Galatians 69 and let us not
grow weary while doing good for in due
season we shall reap if we do not lose
heart just know that we love you we
thank you thank you for spending this
time with us God bless you
[Music]
amen